hi everyone my name is well and I work
in for the mobile web of lead the mobile
web team in London my name is Paul I'm
head of front-end department from Moscow
we both work for Badu a social discovery
platform to meet new people we build web
and native applications which allow more
than 200 million users across 190
countries to meet each other around the
world
sorry I'm late the mobile web team and
we've recently been real connecting a
lot of the way that we access our API
layer and got to talk some a bit about
that so in the background problems with
API I was going to discuss some details
about how we've implemented that and
then I'm going to finish off with some
examples of how we actually use the
tools we've built to build an actual
service so first of all what is an API
well API is an application programming
interface
in simple terms that's connecting your
client side and your back-end services
together transferring some data between
the two we have some general operations
some inputs some outputs and that
generally has some kind of type
semantics around that but most of all
it's implicated in dependent of the
implementation we actually use to create
it simple so what are our requirements
for building a good API we want a
perfect one well it just wants to work
who wants to be magic what does that
mean once we flexible extensible
testable maintainable and platform and
language neutral but most of all we
don't want it to get in the way we just
want to focus on building great features
and not the bytes that we're sending
over the wire so how can you split up
sections of an API into sort of three
main areas well first of all you've got
encoding thisis what
actually send over the wire the the
format of the data we're sending
backwards and forwards then we have some
rules about what messages we want to
send in what situations and how we deal
with them processing them client-server
side and then once we've actually got
our messages from A to B we want some
general helper methods and access to
that data and forms of getters and
setters and general validation that we
do on our messages so how does that look
in a sort of a classic API example
wrestling Jason we're pretty much all
building web services in one way or web
applications in one way or another that
rely on these sort of common
technologies so typically within your
application you're going to make some
Ajax requests encode that of some euro L
that we send over the wire the server is
going to match that based on some of
your I we've probably got some PHP
object or some some node logics that
will format that data in the response we
want send it back through the system
over the wires adjacent objects we're
going to parse it and code it and then
we're going to go through some similar
validations JavaScript side and use that
within our business logic but what are
some of the problems we see with this
and why we haven't chosen this in an
example for how we've built our API well
we have to some differently encoding
semantics in what semantics that diagram
looks fairly symmetric but actually
server-side we're sending JSON back to
the client but client-side way encoding
that data as urls and telling about both
ways what happens if we want to send
data back the other way and how do we
deal with that message exchange we're
kind of limited if we're using this
example to making requests from the
client and the server selling as
responses but what if we want server to
initiate those responses sure we could
use WebSockets or something allowed to
push messages back but then we've got to
have another layer of system that we
deal with that logic as well we can't
build it all into the same thing very
easily and data access so there's no
scent when we're building up a REST API
we've got different parts of our company
dealing with each other we probably
resort down to having some wiki page
somewhere that describes
this thing's going to work we don't
actually have some process defined
within the the use of this API that we
can use for ensuring that it's working
the same way both sides and so
consequently we don't have easy
versioning and we end up with duplicate
code on one side or the other so but
dudes api's how does how does this fit
into terms of some of the things that
we're doing well we've got a lot of data
bases in memory caches high-performance
daemon services that allow us to scale
out to our 200 million users and they're
connected via some native non-natives a
binary interface to a core web api that
happens to be built in PHP from that we
have our main desktop site on dub dub
dub which connects into that API and
builds out the features for our main
users this API didn't really suit our
mobile experience when we came to build
this out later so on top of this we have
a mobile API core that sits in Topsham
presents a slightly different view from
there we have some native applications
for iOS Android and Windows Store that
again have a binary interface that they
use connecting this mate API then the
first thing we did off that was well we
have a desktop site and a native site
but we don't have a mobile website and
the site wasn't suitable being
responsive we had some designs for
mobile we decided we'd build a
essentially a feature phone version of
the site that connects into the same
mobile API that uses Java as its
technology and it again allows that to
use the same native interface for
building that site out then 18 months
two years ago we decided we want a
single page web application and of
course we connected it straight into the
mobile API and use the same thing but we
didn't because sadly we didn't we
couldn't use those new technologies out
of the the binary technologies out of
the box so we ended up providing another
API layer on top of the Java site and
providing a sort of semi restful service
there so recently we've been drawing
that arrow back in the right direction
and I'm gonna pass over to power now
that's going to talk about some of the
ways that we use those experiences for
building a native app and actually
allowed us to encoding
in a more web friendly way I will talk
about the solution we ended up with and
some key points that you should keep in
mind designing the protocol there are a
lot of protocol implementations on
market but some of them are all
engineered some have too much XML inside
some force developer to write in machine
readable language so none of them are
perfect so let's take all best parts of
the different solutions and allow I'm
kidding we won't tell you about building
another universal API probably you know
what happens if you try to build a
universal solution which sauce all the
problem instead of that I will tell you
about the problems we found during
design our protocol and how we have
solved them so what should be their
protocol values first of all we want to
have a protocol description which is
independent from language and platform
that I use in the API I want API to be
available for all platforms including
Java Objective C Android all the stuff
want to be its CPU and network efficient
on the same platforms we want to have a
nice data access class which get a
status and validation hidden inside we
want we don't want to have a config
separate conflict with all the roads who
were to send a message to get something
back we want to put it inside the
protocol and of course because we are
feature rich product and we want to
deliver new features fast want to have
versioning because all of you know how
long does it take to pass the approval
prods from Apple or from Google and
still users doesn't update instantly so
we designed we decided to take a look at
Google protocol buffers which is used in
our back-end to the backend
communication and try to bring
- client-server communication we can
take a look at the same diagram we have
4r s + JSON we want encoding to be
protocol buffers only both sides we want
to have a kind of event based system to
handle all the messages and take
decision what's what what's K came to
other end and want to have a generated
class with a nice API dependent on a
protocol which can be different
depending on the platform and we want a
protocol description and versioning be
independent out of technological stack
I want to like automate as much as
possible so let's take a closer look at
Google protocol buffers first of all
they have a very nice interface
definition language with which actually
have all the features that we need
internal representation is also very
good we can easily extend the protocol
itself and like internal stuff in case
we have to patch the compiler things
like that in terms of language support
google ship support only for C++ Java
and Python
so at 2009 when we start looking at this
thing there were no support for PHP and
JavaScript we needed but in 2010 Google
landed protocol buffers compiler plugins
which actually allow you to write your
own implementation firing language we
need and it's very encoding a versi
encoding is very CPU and network
efficient because it's binary and there
are a lot of like comparison markings at
it it is efficient let's take a look at
at details of Google buffers
first of all interface description
language have a number of entities which
are enumerations messages filled with
typed fields and a simple service layer
all of those entities have options which
you can treat as a method data which
which describes details of the message
but isn't passed along the wire and the
main advantage of interfaces Google
implementation of the compiled and
interface description language itself is
that it is self describing so result of
parsing a proto file is a protocol
buffers message and descriptor proto is
a brilliant stuff let's take a look at
detail so field can be repeatable
optional or required in case you want
set required fields as a message want to
validate and won't be so realized you
can filter Peter as an array so you can
set 0 or more values of that field
interface description language have a
white type system including messages and
enumerations which allow you to describe
any nested structures and all the fields
have numbers fill numbers give us is a
perfect vision in I will stop at that a
bit later here's a couple of examples so
we had here require string username with
the first field and optional and science
H and the second one here is a small
example of how does a message look in
the profile William will give a couple
of real-world examples a bit later so we
have a nice in description language we
can describe our protocol let's find out
what we should actually use in
application code we have only binary
encoding out-of-the-box we have a very
simple RPC which probably don't see you
down needs and we don't have a native
support for PHP and JavaScript only a
third party solutions which have a bit
different internal infrastructure so one
ask why we have chosen the solution so
much parts of which we don't like
actually there is an answer it's because
protocol buffers compiler
protocol buffers compiler plugins sorry
they allow us to actually implement our
own coding generate our own classes and
very nicely decouple own things from
each other so internally the
infrastructure of plugins is very nice
you can write you can write a simple
plugin in 20 lines of Python code here's
an example to take a look later and
actually you can write compiler plugins
at any language you like and generate
the code at language that you need and
this architecture makes interface
description language of Google protocol
buffers completely independent of all
other parts from the civilization and
from like RPC and all stuff so return to
the picture
we'll start with have module IP is on
this diagram so we news we use native
encoding for native clients for
communication between PHP and services
and we want to use a JSON encoding
between our side and desktop the stop
browsers and mobile browsers so we try
to build our own solution which encodes
protocol buffers in JSON and it appeared
to be quite performant
but anyway it's not a problem we can
easily plug in initialization or use
binary one or use JSON one or in case
one of us get mad we can even sterilize
in in XML or something crazy like that
so we have a tool which generates our
classes simplified development process
and developer life we want to auto
generate all of that so we change a
proto file add in a field or change in
something we want to generate all the
code all the data access classes and all
the stuff on mobile developer
infrastructure we have a ground task
which does all the work
and on our website we have a bit more
control about over backhand so we can
generate code only in case proto file is
news and generated code on any request
on production we just do a generation
during deploy process so we have a nice
interface description language we have a
tool which auto generates all data
access classes and we have nice and nice
encoding we are happy with let's talk
about message exchange so out of the box
we have services which like simple RPC
implementation RPC is an ability one of
one node to call a remote procedure on
another node and without knowing the
implementation details for me the
services that came with Google protocol
buffers are too simple for a complex
application so first of all we need a
like protocol layer service wrapper
which will contain like message ID
session ID global protocol versions and
things like that so all the requests and
response will be wrapped in a message
also we have a dependencies that we want
to weigh RPC so we need to server to be
able to call a procedure on a client to
show a promise screen to the authorize
client to ask phone operate or anything
but the can guy guys one because we
control the server now we can deploy in
number of minutes but we don't control
the we sorry client control is harder so
and so we built our own RPC
implementation which we call it a
two-way RPC RPC class takes as a
parameter the command ID and protocol
buffers message and you can subscribe to
any message that can came from the
backend
if you want to listen to all RPC
messages you can subscribe on our PC any
layer and listen to all responses that
could possibly come from the server so
you can think about this this as a like
back way server calling procedure on a
client
the callback will receive our nice
generated class with all the types
validated you need to worry about field
existence of field type so it simplifies
application code a lot and actually we
just use the entities we had at the
protocol we used enumeration for math
Shady's of requests and response and
normal GPB messages to pass over the
wire a lot but not least version is very
important so we have out-of-the-box per
field version in so when you pass any
field to a client which don't know about
it it will just ignore it because of
field number I've told a bit earlier and
because of our RPC implementation we can
ignore unsupported comments on a
client's also because we use only
generated data access classes in case
you have removed some field in protocol
and try to use it in a client you will
receive compilation time errors that
that Gator just doesn't exist so in the
end you should define protocol in one
way you know in one place you should use
generated class classes to abstract like
protocol internals from the application
code you should have have validation
inside those generated classes to be
able to switch like even complete
protocol implementations inside without
affecting the application code you can
this way allows you to have different
encodings depending on a situation
you have a building an RPC layer
abstract a lot of like protocol details
and like gives you like observable with
just a simple of cell you listen for
what you want without caring what
actually going on the wire and that
helps you to focus on features not the
protocol details version is also very
very critical so if you go this way
you will end up with implementation
which actually with everything decoupled
and now will will give you a couple of
real world examples of what we have
built on top of that thank you so now
we've got all those tools we want to put
them together and actually go through an
actual real world service so this is a
mobile app we bought a couple of apps
where to do and where to have an app
called hot or not this is a screen from
hot or not and we're typing in a city we
want to change your location and we're
coming up with a list of cities and we
want to click on it and save the
location so what details do we need to
build that service it's quite simple
we're going to send a city name or the
the parts of the city name we've started
typing and we're going to come back with
an ID a list of cities and there's a
latitude and longitude that we don't use
in that screen but we use in another
part of the application and I'm also
going to talk about well one of our
requirements was to weigh our PC we want
the server to initiate communications as
well so we also want a client
notification so in this terms is the
server saying coming to some reason of
state that we need to display a warning
message to the user so these are the
protocol definitions messages that you
need to define the service so first of
all the first primitive the enum message
type defines the command that we send
one way or the command that the server
sends back the other way and we use the
convention here that messages going from
the client to the server start with
server and the message is going from the
server back to the client start with
client that's really just for
readability of other than anything else
and then we define the messages for the
data that we have to send in those
backwards and forwards so for a city
query where research of a city we've
just defined a string and we
deliberately try to make these messages
very semantic in terms of what they're
doing we could just define a string
message in this case and Senate
generically but actually we find that
being specific about the types of
messaging when we send allows us to
easily see their usage within the code
and make them more we factorable and
then the response coming back from your
back-end can be a city's message and you
see here we've got a repeated city
object which is allows you to see you
can nest these things quite quite well
and you get good object-oriented style
structure and then finally you've got
client notification message which has
just got an ID and a title and a message
and we're good we want to display this
in an alert box before we move on
there's a couple of boilerplate things
that are core things that we have to
define once
Pawel talked like a wrapper message that
we need so here we've got our initial
wrapper message and this describes
everything that gets sent over the Orkin
is a container for everything that gets
sent back and forwards and that's got an
Asian and a message ID and then a
message body and as we add new types of
message to our protocol we fill the
message body out with these types of
message and the way Google protocol
buffers works you can all the way the
encoding works is that you can fill that
in with optional fields and you've got
that data available to you so this has
generated class example for Java Script
the details of it don't matter as a
generated class that's the point a
couple of things to take away though it
extends a basic class so there's a base
class which we have control over as well
it's you don't have to edit it on a day
to day basis but it contains your basic
getters and setters some validate some
generic validation for you making sure
everything's happening properly and then
here we have the descriptive information
that we've pulled out of out the proto
definition when we've done our
generation stage from the message into
our into our actual generated class and
then the same thing for PHP you could
use the JavaScript on both sides you
could use you could generate it into
Java we could've ever you want
but again we've extended a base class
which contains our basic functionality
and we've got our descriptor information
that's specific to how we want it
formatted for PHP so now we've got our
generated classes and we're ready to
start using that with our JavaScript RPC
library let's step through how we might
actually do that so we want to make a
new RPC call and send the message type
of service search city so remember
begins our server we're sending it from
client to server and we want to give
that a call back or we want to give that
a city query object which contains the
data that we want to query so first of
all we have to build a new city query
object and do a set name on it with the
name that we ought to do and we pass it
in once we've done that we need to bind
some events in so we want to listen in
this case to client cities and we want
to pass that to a callback when we get a
result from it so this is kind of note
style we pass in an error and then a
cities object and we can either handle
the error that might come on or ignore
it if it's null and then we can loop
through our list of cities and update
some view that we might want to do with
our cities object likewise we can listen
to our client notification event here
and pass that into a callback that we
deal with them personally box and then
finally we send we far a request
function and that actually sends it off
to the server and we wait a sympathy for
the response but wait a minute we said
that we wanted to our listen client
notification on any situation and we've
we don't want to have to go and do on
client notification for every single RBC
callback we make so actually we want to
bind that into the RPC any call that pal
talked about earlier so if we remove
that on client notification message
there and create an RPC on any call we
can bind our client notification in
generically and any time any message
that we send or if we're using a
different communication channel so if we
set WebSockets up or if we have some
other kind of service enabled that
message can get pulled down and we can
encode that and we can it's help alert
for it so that's the end of the examples
and this is sort of quick summary of
what we've gone through we've talked
we've discussed
rest and Jason and why that wasn't
suitable for our case gone through the
protocol values and I've discussed a few
examples so these were our contact
details the slides will be up shortly at
tekzilla.com and if we'll be around for
some questions if you want to catch it
in the hallway later on Thanks
you